وانقص علينا المبنى الخامس واللي وراه
وطلعنا من الولاده رحنا عند غسيل الكلى
كانت
صعبه كانت صعبه طبعا لغايه الان صعبه
الحمد لله على كل حال طبعا كانت عذاب هناك
كانوا في يعني اليهود طبعا دخلت في
المستشفى وطبعا حاجات كثيره حصلت واليوم
طلعونا جابونا على ابو يوسف النجار بس
كلها كانت ايام
صعبه سواء قبل او بعد وبعد كانت كمان اصعب
يعني انحنا عايشين برعب وكوا خوف وما في
اي حاجه لا بتقدر تطلع من قسم لقسم ما
بتقدر تطلع يعني مقطوع الميه مقطو على
الكهرباء ما فيش اي حاجه حتى تبعون غسيل
الكلى ما غسلوا لهم يعني مره او مرتين
طبعا بالقصف صواريخ بالضرب المستشفى من
الداخل من ثم صار في طبعا خلال المعركه
هذه كلها كان في مشكله عننا في العلاج
وتطبيب الاطفال اللي كانوا م جديدين لانه
حصار المستشفى حصار كامل طبعا الميه مش
موجود الاكل مش موجود اي حاجه بدك تلزمك
للتطبيب مش موجوده صار بعد هيك بعد الحصار
صار في استدعاء للمرافقين وللناس
الموجودين مع المرضى وتم الاسئله عن طبعا
مين شفت كيف شفت ايش لقيت في المستشفى
طبعا بيبحثوا عن معلومات معلومات معلومات
معلومات وهذا طبعا كان يعني ضغط كبير كبير
للمريض ول المرافقين تبعين المريض واليهود
كانوا طبعا مقتحم مستشفى الشبه ض ضربوا
قسم الولاده ضربوا العياده الخارجيه رمو
برضك كات والاداره المستشفى لا فيها ميه
ولا فيها كهرباء ولا فيها ميه حلوه ولا
فيها حاجه دبرنا حالها حالنا باللي تفهمه
وقعدنا في في المستشفى تحت الرعب والخوف
اليهود كان بينا وبينهم حيطه عملوا كل
السيارات اللي في المستشفى عملوهم جبل
ركام سيارات جبل كباش اول شي كسروا كسروا
السيارات بعدين عملوا ركام والدبابات تمشي
في نص المستشفى ممنوع من قسم لقسم نتحرك
وبعدين صار لا في غسيل ولا في كهرباء ولا
في
شرب